[Music]
unless you're from new orleans you will
not know nothing about the hangover
hotline
i feel like my head is going to explode
can i please have some of your soup yes
i got that hangover care i'm on my way
my name is chef linda green i am called
the yaakoman lady yagamit is one of new
orleans best kept secret it's a noodle
soup
yakami was classified as a poor man dish
it is chinese
and african american fusion it's good
for the soul it's good for a hangover
oh my god when it hits the tongue it
goes to the brain
and then they come back
to the tongue
and say i want more
my mother was a cafeteria a technician i
was a cafeteria technician too
my mom and my grandmother used to cook
yeah i could meet and she always did
tell me that i may be able one day to
use it and she was right
when katrina hit
everyone lost their jobs
i needed a job after i lost my job with
the school
i was catering
and i was selling alchemy at a lot of
festivals in the city i won
gumbo festival i won sushi festival i've
been winning a lot i've just been very
persistent and consistent with this yoga
man and it became popular and the phone
was ringing off the hook everybody used
to say
where they are can be lady at that's how
i got that name
you know people from all over the world
call me if there's a hotline girl that
deliver or some i'll come and pick it up
i went out on faith
and i never looked back
[Music]
i love my city y'all i'm not gonna tell
y'all world a lot i love my city my name
got known because hangover is very
common in new orleans our yakami is the
best remedy for new alien side headache
everyone call it holds over
i just love what i do
i love cooking i love
for someone
to enjoy my food and i love for them to
come to me and tell me
everything was beautiful
[Music]